This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. There's a place in South Dakota just off Interstate 90. That's one of those tourist attractions that you see hundreds of signs for as you approach. They count down the miles and list the reasons to stop in. Cowboy boots, donuts, cheap coffee, 60 miles ahead, souvenirs, fun for the whole family. That's reporter Phil Corbett from a podcast called The Wind. In a few months ago, while driving across the wide stretching grasslands of South Dakota,
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。南达科他州90号州际公路旁有个地方。那是那种当你临近时会看到数百个路标的旅游景点。它们倒数着英里数，并列举着停下来的理由。牛仔靴、甜甜圈、便宜的咖啡，前方60英里，纪念品，全家同乐。那是来自播客《风》的记者菲尔·科贝特，几个月前，当他开车穿过南达科他州广阔的草原时，
I aimed the wheel off the freeway and followed the signs to the ultimate roadside stop, Wall Drug. We are a fun roadside attraction. We're a slice of Americana, you know. This is Sarah Hustead. Sarah owns wall drug with her dad, and she is the fourth generation of Hustead to run this place. It's in the small town of Wall South Dakota,
我把方向盘开出高速公路，顺着路标来到了终极路边景点——华尔药房。我们是一个有趣的路边景点。你知道的，我们是美国风情的一个切片。这是莎拉·赫斯特德。莎拉和她父亲一起拥有华尔药房，她是经营这个地方的第四代赫斯特德家族成员。它位于南达科他州华尔小镇，
which sits right at the spot where the bad lands crumple up. Above, the Great Plains silently sprawl toward a distant horizon. Sarah's Great Grandfather bought this place as a simple small town pharmacy during the Great Depression, and over nine decades the family expanded this small drugstore to take up an entire city block. And in addition to its restaurant, soda fountain, donut shop, and traveler's chapel, it is a remarkable purveyor of Western Ketch. And that is why I stopped. Not for the cheap coffee, but because wall drug is synonymous with one of my favorite examples of Western Kitch.
这里正好坐落在恶地起伏交错的地方。上方，大平原静静地向远方的地平线延伸。莎拉的曾祖父在大萧条时期买下这里，作为一家简单的小镇药房，在过去的九十年里，家族将这家小型药店扩展到占据了整个街区。除了餐厅、苏打喷泉、甜甜圈店和旅行者小教堂之外，它还是西部俗艳商品（Kitsch）的一个杰出供应商。这就是我停下来的原因。不是为了便宜的咖啡，而是因为华尔药房是我最喜欢的西部俗艳风格代表之一的代名词。
We are looking at a full wall of jackalopes. The jackalope. Looks like we've sold some here, but we have four rows of solid jackalopes and they have their nice wood planks and the beautiful jack rabbits with the real antlers. If you're not familiar with the jackalope, this magical mythical creature is a horned rabbit. And though I've seen many lone mounted jackalope heads, I am struck by the variety,
我们正看着一整面墙的杰卡洛普（鹿角兔）。杰卡洛普。看起来我们这里卖了一些，但我们有四排满满的杰卡洛普，它们有好看的木板和漂亮的、带着真鹿角的野兔。如果你对杰卡洛普不熟悉，这种神奇的神话生物就是一只长角的兔子。虽然我见过许多单独装裱的杰卡洛普头标本，但我还是被它的多样性震撼了，
seeing them side by side in rows. Oh, I think his lips are kind of perched and he's looking quite perky here. I would call this guy a little more wierry. And then you have the nice kind of more wintery jackalops that are nice and white, super fluffy. And I think those ones are extra cute. The antlers are of different sizes and shapes. The rabbits all have different expressions.
看到它们一排排并排在一起。哦，我觉得它的嘴唇有点翘起，看起来神采奕奕。我会把这家伙叫做更有野性一点。然后你还有那些更像冬天的杰卡洛普，它们很白，超级蓬松。我觉得那些特别可爱。鹿角的大小和形状各不相同。兔子的表情也各不相同。
Some rye and knowing, others calm and wide-eyed, but all of them with a certain straight-faced charm. died, but all of them with a certain straight-faced charm. Do you have a jackalope? At home? Yeah. Of course. For the past 70 years, wall drug has been central in the spread of this iconic creature. I wouldn't want to say wall drug is responsible.
有些狡猾而心领神会，有些平静而睁大眼睛，但它们都带有一种一本正经的魅力。死去了，但它们都带有一种一本正经的魅力。你家里有一个杰卡洛普吗？有。当然。在过去的70年里，华尔药房一直是这种标志性生物传播的核心。我可不想说华尔药房该负全责。
I wouldn't want to get too big of a head, but we do see a ton of people from all over come through, and here is probably the first time that they're seeing the Jackalope. But the story of how the Jackalope became a mythical mascot of the American West, inspiring an absolute river of trinkets and songs and whiskeys and postcards and tall tales, that story goes back much further than Wall Troc. The way most people encounter the jackalope is not in the wild, but instead on a wall. Yeah, pool hall, a bar, a greasy spoon diner, and maybe your grandfather's basement.
我可不想自我感觉太好，但我们确实看到来自各地的成千上万的人到这里来，而这里很可能是他们第一次看到杰卡洛普。但关于杰卡洛普如何成为美国西部神话吉祥物的故事，激发了绝对如河流般的小饰品、歌曲、威士忌、明信片和高调的谎言，那个故事要比华尔药房的历史久远得多。大多数人遇到杰卡洛普的方式不是在野外，而是在墙上。是的，台球室、酒吧、油腻的勺子小餐馆，也许还有你爷爷的地下室。
This is Michael Branch, who wrote a book called On the Trail of the Jackalope. He spent years driving around the American West, talking to everyone who knew anything about jackalopes, in a quest to understand where this creature came from, and why it stuck around for so long. According to Mike, the first documented taxidermy jackalope was made by two young brothers in the early 1930s. Ralph and Doug Herrick lived on a little homestead outside of a tiny town called Douglas Wyoming out on the edge of the prairie, and those kids had been taken a taxidermy course as a correspondence course through the mail. Like many depression era families, the young herix hunted and fished to help stock the family dinner
这是迈克尔·布兰奇，他写了一本名为《追踪杰卡洛普》的书。他花了好几年时间开车穿过美国西部，与所有了解杰卡洛普的人交谈，试图弄清楚这种生物来自何方，以及为什么它能存在这么久。据迈克说，第一个有记载的杰卡洛普标本是由两个年轻兄弟在20世纪30年代初制作的。拉尔夫和道格·赫里克住在怀俄明州一个小镇外的一个小宅地里，就在大草原的边缘，这两个孩子通过邮件函授课程学习了标本制作。像许多大萧条时期的家庭一样，年轻的赫里克兄弟通过打猎和钓鱼来帮助充实家庭的晚餐
table. And they had been out hunting one day and they'd bagged a jackrabbit. They came back and threw it on the floor of their shop. And as the story goes, it slid up against some deer antlers from a deer that had been dressed out not long before. I'm not totally understanding the physics of this scene, but it's okay. Let's continue. And that gave them the idea in that moment when they saw that weird hybrid thing sitting on the floor of their shop, let's mount that thing. And that was the first jackalope head mounted on a plaque. This was the hoax mount that started it all. These two kids taking a taxidermy class
桌子。有一天他们出去打猎，捕获了一只野兔。他们回来后把它扔在车间的地板上。根据故事的说法，它滑到了一只不久前刚剥好皮的鹿的鹿角旁边。我不太理解这个场景的物理学原理，但没关系。我们继续。这在那个时刻给了他们灵感，当他们看到那个奇怪的混合体躺在车间的地板上时，让我们把它做成标本。那是第一个被装裱在牌匾上的杰卡洛普头。这就是这一切的开始的恶作剧标本。这两个孩子通过邮件
through the mail apparently did a pretty good job because they brought the mount down to the local pub where the bar owner paid them 10 bucks for it. To that particular first jackalope, hung in the old LaBonte hotel in Douglas, Wyoming over the bar from the 1930s all the way through the 1970s and that was the rock that got thrown in the pond and the jackalope ripples went out from there across the country and across the whole world really. The Herrick Brothers kept making these things and they probably would have remained just a local Wyoming oddity, if not for Waldrug,
上标本制作课显然做得相当不错，因为他们把标本带到了当地的酒吧，酒吧老板为此付了他们10美元。那个特定的第一个杰卡洛普，从20世纪30年代一直到70年代，一直挂在怀俄明州道格拉斯市老拉博特酒店的吧台上方，那是投进池塘的一颗石子，杰卡洛普的涟漪从那里扩散到全国，甚至整个世界。赫里克兄弟一直在制作这些东西，如果不是因为华尔药房，它们可能仍然只是怀俄明州当地的一个奇观，
which has been selling jackalopes for at least 70 years. The reason Waldrug is such a vital part of the story of the jackalope is that it was probably the first place that ever commercially sold jackalopes, and they have never stopped since. Long before the internet, Waldrug helped the jackalope go viral. Tourists and road trippers from all over the world would stop in at this roadside in Poryom and see on the wall this rabbit with antlers. As more people came into contact with the antler rabbit, a torrent of tall tails followed, an elaborate mythology sprung up around the creature dreamed up by many different storytellers.
华尔药房销售杰卡洛普已经至少70年了。华尔药房之所以成为杰卡洛普故事中如此至关重要的一部分，是因为它可能是第一个商业化销售杰卡洛普的地方，而且他们从此从未停歇。早在互联网出现之前，华尔药房就帮助杰卡洛普病毒式传播。来自世界各地的游客和自驾游者都会在这个路边小店停下来，在墙上看到这只长着角的兔子。随着越来越多的人接触到这只长角的兔子，随之而来的是大量的高调谎言，围绕着由许多不同的讲故事者构成的这种生物，出现了一个精心制作的神话。
Nobody owns the jackalow. No corporation or person is entitled to control its distribution, its consumption, its interpretation. It is truly part of the folk process. According to Jackalob lore, the creatures are smart and considerably dangerous. They only mate during lightning storms, and if you put out a bowl of whiskey at night, a passing jackalob may finish it off, and in his drunken bravado, he'll believe he can catch bullets in his teeth, which is the only way a hunter's can manage to bag them. Also, Jacklope Milk is supposedly a powerful aphrodisiac, and even though the Jacklope sleeps on its back, it's incredibly dangerous to milk on. And finally, the Jacklope is the only animal that can throw its voice like a ventriloquist.
没有人拥有杰卡洛普。没有任何公司或个人有权控制它的分销、消费、解释。它确实是民间传统的一部分。根据杰卡洛普的传说，这些生物很聪明，而且相当危险。它们只在雷雨闪电时交配，如果你在晚上放一碗威士忌，路过的杰卡洛普可能会把它喝光，在它醉醺醺的虚张声势中，它会相信自己能用牙齿接住子弹，这是猎人设法捕获它们的唯一方法。此外，杰卡洛普的奶据说是一种强烈的春药，尽管杰卡洛普是仰面睡觉的，但给它挤奶极其危险。最后，杰卡洛普是唯一能像腹语表演者一样抛出声音的动物。
If you're out camping and you're singing around the campfire, you'll hear that voice coming in from the sage of the jackalope harmonizing with you. Throughout history, people have told stories about chimera. The original chimera, from Greek mythology, was a fire-breathing monster with a lion's head, a goat's body, and a serpent's tail. Over time, the word has come to mean any hybrid creature made up of different animal parts. Horses with wings, cats with eagle heads, fish with fur. When inventing something new, the oldest trick in the book is to smash two existing things together.
如果你在野外露营，在篝火旁唱歌，你会听到那个声音从杰卡洛普的鼠尾草丛中传出来，与你和谐共鸣。在整个历史中，人们一直在讲述关于喀迈拉的故事。最初的喀迈拉来自希腊神话，是一个喷火的怪物，长着狮子的头、山羊的身子和蛇的尾巴。随着时间的推移，这个词演变成指由不同动物部件组成的任何混合生物。带翅膀的马，长着老鹰头的猫，带毛的鱼。当发明新东西时，书中最古老的把戏就是把两个现有的东西砸在一起。
But the jackalope chimera distinctly fits into the American West, and it emerged at a particular moment in the West's history. Early in the country's Western colonization, Frontiersmen and settlers were often seen from the East as bumpkins, uncultured and immoral people living in a wild land. But going into the 1900s, pop culture started to romanticize the West. People loved stories about heroic cowboys living on the prairie, the stuff that you'd see in Buffalo Bill's Wild West show. Over time, the diverse and complicated reality of the West was slowly flattened into a simpler and more
但杰卡洛普这种喀迈拉明显符合美国西部的特色，它诞生于西部历史上的一个特定时刻。在该国西部开拓的早期，前沿开拓者和定居者从东部人的眼中经常被视为乡巴佬，是不懂文化、不道德的、生活在野蛮土地上的人。但进入20世纪后，流行文化开始将西部浪漫化。人们喜欢关于生活在大草原上的英雄牛仔的故事，这些你在布法罗·比尔的西部狂野表演中都能看到。随着时间的推移，西部多元而复杂的现实慢慢被简化为一个更简单、更
whitewashed myth. Part of that romantic retelling included an interest in the actual Western tradition of tall tales. That language of hyperbole, of exaggeration, of larger than life, so that's part of what we associate with the American West, right? Is this wonderful tradition of extravagant folk humor? Settlers as early as the mid-1800s used humor and embellishment to subvert the narrative that they were ignorant. I think the tension between the East and West in the United States from the 19th century forward is a really important part of the story. You know, people in the American West who may be are seen as frontiersmen or bumpkins
被美化的神话。这种浪漫化重述的一部分包括对实际西部高调谎言传统的兴趣。那种夸张、夸大、超越生命本身的语言，所以这就是我们与美国西部联系在一起的一部分，对吧？是这种奇妙的夸张民间幽默传统？早在19世纪中期，定居者就用幽默和润色来颠覆他们无知的叙述。我认为19世纪以来美国东西部之间的紧张关系是这个故事中非常重要的一部分。你知道，美国西部的人可能被视为开拓者、乡巴佬
or uneducated, they say, oh, yeah, well, guess what? I know more than you do about something, and it's this. I'm going to fool you with this jackalope. There's a great satisfaction in taking someone who is condescending or elite and exposing their ignorance when they're busy trying to expose yours. Some of the jackalops allure is that it sets up this ruse. There are people who know, and people who don't. And a lot of the satisfaction comes from playing with that line.
或是没受过教育的人，他们会说，哦，是的，好吧，你猜怎么着？关于某件事我知道得比你多，就是这个。我要用这个杰卡洛普愚弄你。把一个居高临下或自诩精英的人拉下神坛，当他们忙着暴露你的无知时却暴露了他们自己的无知，这会带来巨大的满足感。杰卡洛普的魅力之一在于它布下了这个骗局。有懂的人，也有不懂的人。而大部分的满足感来自于玩味这条界限。
Telling people a long, just barely plausible story, all the while pointing to the evidence right there on the wall. Like all good humorous, the Jackalope always keeps a straight face. It refuses to acknowledge that it's funny in any way. It takes itself perfectly seriously. But there's a curious thing about horned rabbits. While we know the origin story of the jackalope, Douglas Wyoming, 1932. There are illustrations and descriptions of this specific creature going back much, much further. For instance, there's a Renaissance illustration of a squirrel and three rabbits, the central one sporting a crown of antlers. Or there's a Flemish painting from the 17th century that shows a wreath of fruit and flowers
给人们讲述一个漫长的、勉强说得过去的故事，同时指着墙上的证据。像所有优秀的幽默一样，杰卡洛普总是保持着一张扑克脸。它拒绝承认自己有任何滑稽之处。它极其严肃地对待自己。但关于长角的兔子，有一个奇怪的事情。虽然我们知道杰卡洛普的起源故事是1932年的怀俄明州道格拉斯。但关于这种特定生物的插图和描述可以追溯到更早、更早的时候。例如，有一幅文艺复兴时期的插图，画的是一只松鼠和三只兔子，正中间的那只头戴鹿角冠。或者有一幅17世纪的佛兰芒画作，上面画着一圈水果和鲜花，
surrounded by birds, deer and a small horned rabbit. And this is not just in Europe. Horned rabbits show up all over the world. Indigenous people from Mexico and the Americas, there are horned rabbit tails in the folklore of many African peoples, certainly all across Europe, and then in Asia. A horned rabbit is even invoked in early Buddhist texts, as a way to talk about the very nature of reality. Basically, the Buddha says to his students, If you think a horned rabbit exists, then you don't understand anything about the world
周围环绕着鸟类、鹿和一只长角的小兔子。这不仅在欧洲。长角的兔子在世界各地都有出现。来自墨西哥和美洲的原住民，许多非洲人民的民间传说中都有长角兔子的尾巴，当然还有整个欧洲，然后是亚洲。长角的兔子甚至在早期佛教经文中被提及，作为讨论现实本质的一种方式。基本上，佛陀对他的学生说：如果你认为长角的兔子存在，那么你对这个世界一无所知
or about human consciousness because obviously it doesn't exist. And then he'd ask his students to picture a horn rabbit. And he'd say, well the horn rabbit is real to you now, isn't it? So if you think the horn rabbit doesn't exist, you don't know anything about reality or the nature of the mind. So he used it as a tool to kind of break down this binary thinking the specific lesson was that the horn rabbit both does and doesn't exist. And that line between real and not real blurs with the horned rabbit because they don't only show up in art and mythology. Early cosmographies and natural histories will depict the horn rabbit and
或者对人类意识一无所知，因为很明显它并不存在。然后他会要求他的学生想象一只长角的兔子。他会说，嗯，现在这只长角的兔子对你来说是真实的，对吧？所以如果你认为长角的兔子不存在，你对现实或心灵的本质一无所知。所以他把它作为一个工具来打破这种二元思维，具体的教训是长角的兔子既存在又不存在。而真实与虚幻之间的界限在长角的兔子身上变得模糊，因为它们不仅出现在艺术和神话中。早期的宇宙志和自然历史会描绘长角兔子，
then throughout the late medieval and Renaissance periods in Europe, the horn rabbit was actually taxonomized as a unique species. It was called lepus cornudus. And so if rabbits with horns are depicted all over the world in art from nearly every continent and in natural history, is there actually a lepus cornudus? A taxonomized distinct species? No, they were wrong on that. But... Horned rabbits actually exist in nature. The horned rabbit is real, sort of. Most of what we know about the existence of Hornrabbits is thanks to a pioneering
然后在欧洲的中世纪晚期和文艺复兴时期，长角兔子实际上被归类为一个独特的物种。它被称为lepus cornudus（有角野兔）。所以，如果长角的兔子在几乎各大洲的艺术品中以及自然历史中都被描绘在世界各地，真的有lepus cornudus吗？一个被分类的独特物种？不，他们在这一点上弄错了。但是……自然界中确实存在长角的兔子。长角的兔子是真的，某种程度上。我们对长角兔子存在的大部分了解都要归功于一位开拓性的
virologist named Richard Schoep. Schoep was born in Des Moines, Iowa in 1901 and by the 1930s he was working at the Rockefeller Institute at Princeton University. That's where he discovered what caused the pandemic of 1918 by linking the influenza virus to one he observed in pigs. Shope was well-established in his field and he was an expert on animal-to-human disease transmission. Shope has two living children, and though neither could do an interview for this story, his daughter Nancy shared some of her dad's unpublished letters, which were incredible
病毒学家，名叫理查德·肖普（Richard Shope）。肖普1901年出生于衣阿华州得梅因，到20世纪30年代，他在普林斯顿大学的洛克菲勒研究所工作。正是在那里，他通过将流感病毒与他在猪身上观察到的病毒联系起来，发现了1918年大流行的病因。肖普在自己的领域里基础扎实，他是动物传染给人疾病传播的专家。肖普有两个健在的孩子，虽然他们两人都无法接受这个故事的采访，但他的女儿南希分享了她父亲的一些未发表的信件，读起来非常
to read. Here is Richard Schoep describing his own work, in a letter he sent in 1932 to his mom. February 22, 1932. You asked what to tell people that asked you what my work was. Just tell them that I work with diseases, the causes of which are unknown, trying to find the cause, and to study the pathology. At this time, a show had conducted research that convinced them that viruses could cause certain kinds of cancer in mammals. The scientific community hadn't caught up with them yet, but
令人惊叹。这里是理查德·肖普在1932年写给他母亲的一封信中描述他自己的工作。1932年2月22日。你问当别人问你我的工作是什么时该告诉他们什么。只要告诉他们我从事病因不明的疾病研究，试图找到病因，并研究病理学。此时，肖普已经进行了研究，使他们确信病毒会导致哺乳动物的某些癌症。科学界还没有赶上他，但
that would change, starting in 1932. That year, the same year the Herrick Brothers mounted their first jackalope in Wyoming, Shope started hearing about some strange horned rabbits in the Midwest. Not the ones the Hericks were making, but real rabbits that hunters had come across on the Great Plains. And so he asked these hunters to essentially start mailing him these weird rabbits from the Midwest. When the rabbits arrived at his lab, Shope could see that the rabbits didn't actually have
从1932年开始，这种情况将发生改变。那一年，也就是赫里克兄弟在怀俄明州装裱他们的第一个杰卡洛普的那一年，肖普开始听到中西部出现一些奇怪的长角的兔子。不是赫里克兄弟制作的那种，而是猎人在大平原上偶然遇到的真正的兔子。于是他要求这些猎人基本上开始给他寄来这些来自中西部的奇怪兔子。当兔子到达他的实验室时，肖普可以看出兔子其实并没有
horns. They had these gnarly disturbing growths that were caused, Shope thought, by some kind of disease. Shope collected samples of the growths. Then he pulverized them, did some, you know, science stuff, and as a result, he would get a mix of organic material all contained in a fluid. That fluid would be strained through a porcelain filter. When it was strained through that filter, lots of genetic material and lots of bacterial material would
角。肖普认为，它们身上有这些因某种疾病引起的奇形怪状、令人不安的赘生物。肖普收集了这些赘生物的样本。然后他把它们粉碎，做了一些，你知道的，科学的事情，结果，他会得到混合在液体中的所有有机物质。该液体将通过瓷质过滤器进行过滤。当通过该过滤器过滤时，大量的遗传物质和大量的细菌物质将被
be filtered out. Shope applied that filtered fluid to healthy rabbits, who then developed the same growths. So whatever this disease was, it was transmissible. But because of this filtration process, he was able to prove that all the other things it might be had been filtered out, and the only thing small enough to go through that porcelain filter was a virus. That virus that show up extracted is what's called a papilloma virus. And that can cause these really grotesque growths on the animal's head, which can look a lot like horns. They are pretty terrible to look at. I do not recommend googling it. But basically these growths
过滤掉。肖普将这种过滤后的液体涂抹在健康的兔子身上，随后这些兔子身上也长出了同样的赘生物。所以无论这种疾病是什么，它都是会传染的。但由于这个过滤过程，他能够证明所有其他可能是的东西都已经被过滤掉了，唯一小到足以穿过那个瓷质过滤器的东西是一种病毒。肖普提取的这种病毒被称为乳头瘤病毒（Papillomavirus）。这会导致动物头上出现这些非常怪异的赘生物，看起来很像角。它们看起来确实很糟糕。我不建议谷歌搜索它。但基本上这些赘生物
are carcinomas, that sometimes grow quite large and often on the rabbit's face and head. I would definitely say that a rabbit stricken with papilloma virus is likely to look more grotesque and less stylized than an actual jackalote. In most cases, growths emerged from the rabbit's face or the back of its head, but in some instances, they grow right out of the rabbit's forehead and look uncannily like antlers or goat horns. It's hard to say for sure, but it is certainly possible that these rabbits with horns and antlers that were showing up in renaissance paintings and naturalist field books were depictions of this disease observed in nature. Now, at the time, the scientific community didn't believe that viruses could cause cancer, as Chopra wrote in a letter to a colleague. If it's true, the observation would hurt lots of people's feelings that have for a long time
是癌，有时会长得相当大，通常在兔子的脸上和头上。我绝对可以说，患有乳头瘤病毒的兔子看起来可能比真正的杰卡洛普更怪异，更不具风格化。在大多数情况下，赘生物从兔子的脸部或脑后长出，但在某些情况下，它们直接从兔子的前额长出，看起来诡异地像鹿角或山羊角。很难确切地说，但文艺复兴时期的绘画和自然主义者的野外手册中出现的这些长着角和鹿角的兔子，当然有可能是对自然界中观察到的这种疾病的描绘。现在，当时科学界不相信病毒会导致癌症，正如肖普在一封写给同事的信中所写的那样。如果这是真的，这一观察将伤害许多人的感情，他们长期以来
considered tumors as invariably a non-infectious nature. Cancer isn't contagious, right? Well, show by studying those horned rabbits was able to prove that those weird growths were caused by a virus. And that was a major breakthrough because proving that a virus could cause cancer in a mammal opened the way to all kinds of research that was going to turn out to be important to human beings.
认为肿瘤本质上总是非传染性的。癌症不是传染性的，对吧？嗯，肖普通过研究那些长角的兔子，能够证明这些奇怪的赘生物是由病毒引起的。这是一个重大的突破，因为证明病毒会导致哺乳动物患癌症，为各种最终对人类至关重要的研究开辟了道路。
By the 1970s and 80s, researchers were starting to explore the link between papaloma viruses and humans and certain kinds of cancer. It took years to prove the connection, but eventually researchers did, and they won the Nobel Prize for the discovery. We now know that HPV can cause various types of cancer in people. But the most prominent example is cervical cancer, which was a huge, huge killer. Over 90% of cervical cancer is caused by HPV infection, but decades after the work on papilloma viruses by Richard Shope, scientists use that early research to develop a vaccine. If you connect the dots, this leads eventually to development of the human papilloma virus
到20世纪70年代和80年代，研究人员开始探索人类乳头瘤病毒与人类以及某些类型癌症之间的联系。证明这种联系花了数年时间，但研究人员最终做到了，他们因这一发现而获得了诺贝尔奖。我们现在知道HPV可以导致人类患上各种类型的癌症。但最突出的例子是宫颈癌，这是一个巨大的杀手。超过90%的宫颈癌是由HPV感染引起的，但在理查德·肖普对乳头瘤病毒进行研究几十年后，科学家们利用早期研究开发了一种疫苗。如果你把这些点连起来，这最终会导致人类乳头瘤病毒
vaccine, the HPV vaccine, which is the safest, most effective anti-cancer vaccine we have ever created. It saves millions of lives every year, and it would not exist without horned rabbits, and without a person who was curious enough to ask, how did these weird rabbits come to be the way they are. Mike lays out in the book that there is something charming and inexplicable.
疫苗（HPV疫苗）的开发，这是我们创造的最安全、最有效的抗癌疫苗。它每年挽救数百万人的生命，如果没有长角的兔子，如果没有一个足够好奇的人去问，这些奇怪的兔子是怎么变成这样的，它就不会存在。迈克在书中指出，有一种迷人而莫名其妙的东西。
That Richard Chopes' work on horned rabbits began in 1932. 1932 is the year that the Herrick Brothers, in that little town in Wyoming, claimed that they made their first jack-o-lope hoax mount. I don't think there's any relationship between those two things, but I love the idea that, in the same year, this river forks, and one fork is a kind of hoax that is going to become a staple of popular culture,
理查德·肖普对长角兔子的研究始于1932年。1932年是怀俄明州那个小镇的赫里克兄弟声称他们制作了第一个杰卡洛普恶作剧标本的那一年。我认为这两者之间没有任何联系，但我喜欢这个想法，在同一年，这条河分叉了，一个分叉是那种将成为流行文化主食的恶作剧，
and the other fork is this legitimate scientific research that is going to lead to the saving of millions of lives. So the jackalope story turns out to be so much more complicated than we would ever guess when we stick a stamp on a tacky postcard or we see a taxidermy mound in a pool hall. The jackalope so artfully inhabits this space between the fake and the real. It is a true boundary crosser. Name your incongruity, right? Is it a rabbit or deer? Is it timid or vicious?
而另一个分叉是这种将导致挽救数百万人生命的合法科学研究。因此，事实证明，杰卡洛普的故事比我们在俗气的明信片上贴邮票或在台球室里看到动物标本时所能猜想的要复杂得多。杰卡洛普非常巧妙地栖息在虚假和真实之间的这个空间里。它是一个真正的越界者。说出你的不协调之处，对吧？它是兔子还是鹿？它是胆小还是凶残？
Is it funny or serious? Is it ironic or genuine? Back at Waldruck, I amble across the courtyard. I pass a taxidermy buffalo and the threshold of the back building and duck into a hallway filled with remarkable historic photographs. Young cowboys on the Great Plains hold tight to bucking Broncos, settlers traverse the windswept grasslands, indigenous families and chiefs posed together in traditional garb, standing on the land they've inhabited for millennia.
它是滑稽还是严肃？它是讽刺的还是真诚的？回到华尔药房，我在庭院里漫步。我走过一头美洲野牛标本和后楼的门槛，钻进一条挂满引人注目的历史照片的走廊。大平原上的年轻牛仔紧紧抓着狂野的野马，定居者穿过风沙吹拂的草原，原住民家庭和酋长们身着传统服饰摆姿势拍照，站在他们世代居住的土地上。
And this sincere, quiet collage of deep American history is interrupted every 12 minutes by a giant animatronic T-Rex. The American West can be a weird place. Beautiful and ugly, sincere and commodified serene and absurd. And overseeing all of it, up on the wall, is the antler drabbit, always with a straight face. Alright, I think just one final question, is the jackalope real or is it myth? Yes. Coming up after the break, I talked with Phil about the jackalope in pop culture and how it connects with the long tradition of the trickster. So, Phil, you're back to talk with us a little bit more about the Jackalope and its relationship with arts and culture.
而这幅真诚、安静的美国深厚历史拼贴画，每12分钟就被一个巨大的电子霸王龙打断一次。美国西部可以是一个奇怪的地方。美丽而丑陋，真诚而商品化，宁静而荒谬。而这一切的主宰，挂在墙上的是那只长着鹿角的兔子，总是摆出一副扑克脸。好吧，我想最后一个问题，杰卡洛普是真的还是神话？是的。休息过后，我将和菲尔聊聊流行文化中的杰卡洛普，以及它如何与骗子（Trickster）的长久传统联系在一起。所以，菲尔，你回来和我们多聊聊杰卡洛普及其与艺术和文化的关系。
And since your own podcast, The Wind is about listening and sound and music, let's start with some examples of the Jackalope in music. Yeah, the Jackalope has inspired a ton of pop culture. In Mike Branch's book, he devotes about two pages to listing music that mentions the Jackalope. So I just started listening through all of those bands. Okay, great. So what did you find? There are a ton, but just a couple quick highlights
既然你自己的播客《风》是关于聆听、声音和音乐的，让我们从音乐中的杰卡洛普的一些例子开始吧。是的，杰卡洛普激发了大量的流行文化。在迈克·布兰奇的书里，他花了两页左右的篇幅列出提及杰卡洛普的音乐。所以我开始听所有这些乐队的音乐。好的，太棒了。那么你发现了什么？有很多，但这里有几个快速的亮点
to play for you. One is Creepy Jackalope I by Arizona Cow Punk Band Super Suckers. Or here's one from Your Nick of the Woods. This is an extra noisy track called Jackalope Rising by the Phantom Lins. And they're from beautiful downtown Oakland, California? Maybe not downtown, but they're from Oakland, California. Exactly.
放给你听。一个是亚利桑那州牛朋克乐队Super Suckers的《令人毛骨悚然的杰卡洛普I》。或者这是来自你所在地区的另一首。这是一首格外嘈杂的歌曲，由Phantom Lins演唱的《杰卡洛普崛起》。他们来自加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽市中心？也许不是市中心，但他们来自加利福尼亚州奥克兰市。没错。
The list goes on and on and on, but I started realizing that a lot of these musicians were using the jackalope in their song titles and their lyrics, and they were bending genre in these really interesting ways. Okay, so what do you mean by that? Like a lot of the songs just don't neatly fit into pop or punk or black metal or whatever, but we're instead combining all of these different elements into one song. Like the Jackalope itself, this hybrid creature, it sort of evokes the kind of hybrid musical styles as well.
这个名单没完没了，但我开始意识到这些音乐家在他们的歌词和歌名中使用了杰卡洛普，他们以非常有趣的方式扭曲了流派。好吧，你的意思是？就像很多歌曲根本不适合流行、朋克、黑金属或其他什么，而是将所有这些不同的元素结合在一首歌里。就像杰卡洛普本身一样，这种混合生物，它也让人联想到那种混合音乐风格。
Exactly. And so one of the bands that caught my ear was simply called Jackalope. Okay. that caught my ear was simply called Jackalope. A lot of their songs have this kind of like 80s new age jazz fusion thing going on. And they describe themselves as, let's see, synth acoustic punk orachi Navajez. Okay. Okay.
没错。所以吸引我注意的乐队之一名字很简单，就叫杰卡洛普。好吧。吸引我注意的乐队名字很简单，就叫杰卡洛普。他们的许多歌曲都有这种80年代新世纪爵士融合的风格。他们自称为，让我们看看，合成原声朋克或纳瓦霍爵士。好的。好的。
You might need to break that down for me a little bit more, but yeah, go on. So it's co-fronted by a very prominent Native American flute player named R. Carlos Nakai. And like when I say prominent, I mean, you know, if you're imagining what Native American flute sounds like, there's a chance you're imagining his music. Yeah, it's like multiple gold albums, etc., etc. And so I called up our Carlos Nakai to talk about the image of the Jackalope and, you know, what it means to him.
你可能需要为我多做一点分解，但是的，继续吧。所以它的联合主唱是一位非常著名的美洲原住民长笛手，名叫R·卡洛斯·纳凯（R. Carlos Nakai）。就像我说著名的时候，我的意思是，你知道的，如果你在想象美洲原住民长笛听起来是什么样的，你很有可能就是在想象他的音乐。是的，就像多张金唱片等等，等等。所以我打电话给R·卡洛斯·纳凯，谈论杰卡洛普的形象，以及，你知道的，这对意味着什么。
I think the first time I was ever made aware of the jackalote was when I was visiting with friends down at the Mahaviri community in Parker, Arizona. And there was a rabbit with horns in one of the shops and I said, what is that? Nakae was immediately drawn to the jackalote precisely because it is a hybrid creature. It crosses the boundary between rabbit and deer, and there's something just compelling and playful about it for that reason. Also, Nakai's collaborator in the band Larry Jañez is an artist from Yuma, Arizona, and he works a lot with Chicano imagery and ideas of living on a border coming from a bilingual family. So we live in two worlds at once. All of us do. Jackalope is that mixture of cultural awareness.
我想我第一次知道杰卡洛普是我去亚利桑那州帕克市的马哈维里社区拜访朋友的时候。其中一家商店里有一只长角的兔子，我说，那是什么？纳凯立刻被杰卡洛普吸引，正是因为它是一种混合生物。它跨越了兔子和鹿之间的界限，正因如此，它有一种令人着迷且顽皮的特质。此外，纳凯在乐队中的合作者拉里·亚涅斯（Larry Jañez）是来自亚利桑那州尤马的艺术家，他大量运用奇卡诺（Chicano）意象以及生活在双语家庭、身处边界的概念。所以我们同时生活在两个世界里。我们所有人都是。杰卡洛普就是这种文化意识的融合。
This is something we can have a good time with. So for Naga, it's not just about mixing cultures. It's also about breaking down this line between what's funny and what's serious. Exactly. And this is the other thing about the jackalope that makes it so interesting. Is that it fits into this whole tradition of the trickster, which you know, you see in cultures all over the world. Yeah. I'm remembering from the main story, how the jackalope is itself this trickster with, you know, they drink whiskey and they catch bullets with their teeth and throw their voices and even the image of them is used to trick gullible easterners to thinking that they're real, but you're saying that trickster figures appear in lots of cultures. So what are some of those examples?
这是我们可以从中获得快乐的东西。所以对纳凯来说，这不仅是关于融合文化。这也是关于打破滑稽与严肃之间的界限。没错。这就是杰卡洛普另一个有趣的地方。它符合骗子的整个传统，你知道的，你在世界各地的文化中都能看到这一点。是的。我从主线故事中记得，杰卡洛普本身就是这样一个骗子，你知道的，它们喝威士忌，用牙齿接住子弹，还能腹语，甚至它们的形象被用来欺骗轻信的东部人，让他们以为它是真的，但你是说骗子形象出现在许多文化中？那么其中一些例子是什么？
This type of character is common in indigenous stories in North America, specifically coyote and in the Northwest, the crow, who both have major roles in many creation stories, then Eshu in Nigeria, who is the trickster god of the Yoruba people, Hermes, in ancient Greece, Loki from Norse mythology. He changes form and gender. I mean, the definition is fluid, but the trickster just shows up everywhere. And so I'm familiar with some of those, but what makes a trickster? One thing is that they are constantly testing what is socially acceptable. Sometimes they bridge different realities as well. So in some stories, the coyote will be able to pass between the world of the living and the spirit world.
这种类型的角色在北美原住民的故事中很常见，特别是郊狼，在西北部则是乌鸦，它们在许多创世神话中都扮演着重要角色，然后是尼日利亚的埃舒（Eshu），他是约鲁巴人的骗子神，古希腊的赫尔墨斯，北欧神话中的洛基。他会改变形态和性别。我的意思是，定义是流动的，但骗子到处都是。所以其中一些我很熟悉，但什么造就了骗子？其中一点是他们不断测试社会可接受的底线。有时他们也弥合不同的现实。所以在一些故事中，郊狼能够在生者的世界和精神世界之间穿梭。
And they also often up-end power structures, usually through mischief. So Michael Branch told me that at the core of it, the trickster is all about crossing lines. Most of us live in worlds where boundaries are set out for us every day, and those lines have been drawn for us. And there's something exhilarating about breaking out of that, right? So illicit boundary crossing. That's the forte of the trickster. Okay, I'm starting to get some sense of what the trickster is all about.
而且他们也经常颠覆权力结构，通常是通过恶作剧。所以迈克·布兰奇告诉我，核心在于，骗子全在于跨越界限。我们大多数人都生活在一个界限每天都为我们划定的世界里，那些界限是为我们画好的。突破这一点让人感到非常兴奋，对吧？所以非法的跨越界限。那是骗子的强项。好吧，我开始对骗子是怎么回事有了一些概念。
But do you have other examples of how they operate? So it might help to talk about a couple examples from more contemporary culture. One would be George Clooney's character from Obrother Where Are Thou? I mean, that is contemporary in one sense, but also, isn't it based on the Odyssey, which is not very contemporary? Exactly. And Odysseus from the Odyssey is one of those ancient trickster figures. So, in Obrother Were at Thou, Clooney is constantly using his wit and embellishment and straight-up lives to get out of all these sticky situations.
但你还有其他关于他们如何运作的例子吗？所以讨论几个来自更当代文化的例子可能会有帮助。一个是乔治·克鲁尼在《逃狱三王》中的角色。我的意思是，从某种意义上说那是当代的，但同时，它不是基于《奥德赛》吗，《奥德赛》可不太当代？没错。而《奥德赛》中的奥德修斯就是那些古代骗子形象之一。所以，在《逃狱三王》中，克鲁尼不断利用他的机智、润色和彻头彻尾的谎言来摆脱所有这些棘手的困境。
I'm on my hair. And Thornton! We got you surrounded! Damn, we're in a tight spot. That was my hair. And Thornton! We got you surrounded! Damn, we're in a tight spot. Get the gun out of the revenue! Don't try! You know, he starts off in jail, and he lies to his fellow
我是我的头发。还有桑顿！我们包围你们了！该死，我们处境艰难。那是我的头发。还有桑顿！我们包围你们了！该死，我们处境艰难。把枪从税务员身上拿开！别轻举妄动！你知道，他一开始在监狱里，他向他的同狱
prisoners about hidden treasure, so they'll help him go on this big journey to break up his ex-wife's marriage. And throughout the movie, he's super smart and resourceful, but at the same time, he's super smart and resourceful, but at the same time, he is totally fallible, which is basically how the trickster works, like very clever, seemingly all-knowing, but then completely tripped up by lowly desires like hunger or sex or jealousy or even curiosity. Yeah. It's like the trickster is charming because of its fallibility.
犯人撒谎说有隐秘的宝藏，这样他们就会帮他踏上这段伟大的旅程，去破坏他前妻的婚姻。在整部电影中，他超级聪明且足智多谋，但与此同时，他又是完全不可靠的，这基本上就是骗子运作的方式，非常聪明，看似无所不知，但随后却完全被饥饿、性、嫉妒甚至好奇心等卑微的欲望所绊倒。是的。就像骗子因为他的不可靠而迷人。
I'm curious if you have a favorite trickster. So one of my favorite tricksters is one, everybody will be familiar with, which is Bugs Bunny. I never thought about that, but that seems, yeah, that's right on the money, that makes sense. Yeah, because Bugs is constantly defeating this bumbling human hunter, Elmer Fud. And he does it, you know, not through physical strength,
我很好奇你有没有最喜欢的骗子。所以，我最喜欢的骗子之一是每个人都会熟悉的，那就是兔八哥。我从来没想过这一点，但这似乎，是的，完全切中要害，这就说得通了。是的，因为兔八哥不断地击败这个笨手笨脚的人类猎人埃尔默·费德。而且他做到这一点，你知道的，不是通过体力，
but by outsmarting him and basically playing these elaborate pranks. What's the punch? Uh-oh. Anywhere's words, Wabbit? Yeah. Those split laps have been at a style for at least three decades. Really?
而是通过智胜他，基本上是玩这些精心设计的恶作剧。重点是什么？呃-哦。无论什么词，兔八哥？是的。那些开叉裤已经过时至少三十年了。真的吗？
In fact, I wouldn't be caught dead wearing those things. Oh, well, I was just about to take them off. Oh! Oh, question! Oh! The cement is wet hard! Yeah, Doc, that sonny is pulling around. Better put on some sunscreen! Ah, bye-bye! Oh, no, I can't see.
事实上，我打死也不会穿那种东西。哦，好吧，我正打算把它脱下来。哦！哦！出问题了！哦！水泥是湿的，很硬！是的，老兄，那个阳光在晃荡。最好涂点防晒霜！啊，拜拜！哦，不，我看不见了。
And if you think about it, Oh, no, I can't see. And if you think about it, like if Bugs loses in these episodes, he dies, right? Right, right. And yet he's just super cool, nonchalant, and he pretty much always comes out on top. Right, another thing about it, he's so much like the Jackalope. He's this trickster because he's constantly trolling
如果你仔细想想，哦，不，我看不见了。如果你仔细想想，就像如果兔八哥在这些集数中输了，他就死了，对吧？对，对。然而他还是那么超级酷，漫不经心，而且他几乎总是能稳操胜券。没错，关于他的另一件事，他太像杰卡洛普了。他是个骗子，因为他不断地捉弄
Elmer Fud, but he's also a bit of this chimera hybrid because he's this mix between a rabbit and a human. Exactly. Yeah, because he walks on his back feet, he has gloves. He breaks down that line between human and non-human. And like Loki Bugs also messes with gender in these really understated ways. Like, he'll just fluidly play a Fem version of himself
埃尔默·费德，但他也有点像喀迈拉混合体，因为他是兔子和人类的结合体。没错。是的，因为他用后脚走路，戴着手套。他打破了人与非人之间的界限。就像洛基一样，兔八哥也以这些非常低调的方式搞乱了性别。比如，他会非常流畅地扮演一个女性版本的自己，
without making a big thing of it. Or sometimes they do make a big deal of it and he's like a Fem Faital, like really dolled up, as noted by Garth and Wayne's world. But he admits on a hood of a car that he's secretly attracted to Bugs Money. Did you ever find Bugs Bunny attractive when he put on a dress and play a girl bunny?
而不把它当成大不了的事。或者有时他们确实把它当成大件事，他就像一个蛇蝎美人，真的盛装打扮，正如加思和韦恩的世界里所指出的那样。但他在一辆汽车的引擎盖上承认，他暗中被兔八哥吸引。当兔八哥穿上裙子扮演女兔子时，你有没有觉得兔八哥很有吸引力？
No. No. And he said, I, I was just asking. Yeah, and Bugs is just subversive. He's always upsetting power structures. And that's part of what makes him such a great example of a trickster. So yeah, I mean, if you haven't had a chance to visit Wall Drug or see a Jackalope on a wall, I mean, you've definitely got the vibe from Bucks.
没有。没有。他说，我，我只是问问。是的，兔八哥简直就是颠覆性的。他总是颠覆权力结构。这就是为什么他成为骗子如此伟大的一个例子的一部分。所以，是的，我的意思是，如果你还没有机会参观华尔药房或在墙上看到杰卡洛普，我的意思是，你绝对从兔八哥那里感受到了这种氛围。
That's fantastic. Well, this has been so cool. I really appreciate this deep dive into something that I just had no idea there was so much behind the faux mounted heads that you see in Kitchie Western shops. It's been so cool to go on this journey with you. Thank you, Phil. Really appreciate it.
太棒了。好吧，这太酷了。我真的很感激这次深入的探讨，关于一些我以前根本不知道有这么多内涵的东西，那些你在俗气的西部商店里看到的假装裱鹿头。和你一起踏上这段旅程真是太酷了。谢谢你，菲尔。非常感谢。
Yeah, thank you, Roman. 99% of Vizbo was reported this week by Phil Corbett and edited by Executive Producer Delaney Hall. Phil makes a podcast about listening at a handmade desk in the mountains. It's called The Wind. And if you like this story, you might dig the episode Frontier Music, but start at the prologue. Listen and subscribe at thewind.org.
是的，谢谢你，罗曼。“99%隐形”本周由菲尔·科贝特报道，执行制片人德兰妮·霍尔剪辑。菲尔在山里的手工桌前制作一个关于聆听的播客。它叫《风》。如果你喜欢这个故事，你可能会喜欢《边境音乐》这一集，但请从序幕开始听。请在thewind.org上收听并订阅。
Mix this week by Mita Ganatra, fact checking by Graham Haysha, Music by Swan Rale. Kurt Colstedt is our digital director, the rest of the team, includes Christopher Johnson, Vivian Leigh, Chris Perroupet, Emmett Fitzgerald, Martin Gonzales, Joe Rosenberg, Jason De Leon, Jacob Moltenata Medina, Lashmondon, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks this week to Alisa Sobo from San Diego State University and Rick Houston at Waldrug, who we also spoke to for this story. Thanks also to Tom Schoep and Nancy Fitzgerald, who shared their father's letters.
本周由米塔·加纳特拉混音，格雷姆·海沙核实事实，音乐由斯旺·雷尔创作。库尔特·科尔斯特德是我们的数字总监，团队的其他成员包括克里斯托弗·约翰逊、维维安·李、克里斯·佩鲁佩特、埃mett·菲茨杰拉德、马丁·冈萨雷斯、乔·罗森伯格、杰森·德莱昂、雅各布·莫尔特纳塔·梅迪纳、拉什莫ondon、索菲亚·克拉茨克，以及我罗曼·马尔斯。本周特别感谢圣迭戈州立大学的阿里萨·索博和华尔药房的里克·霍斯顿，我们也为这个故事采访了他们。还要感谢汤姆·肖普和南希·菲茨杰拉德，他们分享了他们父亲的信件。
We are part of the Stitcher & Serious XM Podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussion about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. Run Instagram and let it to. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love,
我们是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分，现在总部设在潘多拉大楼以北六个街区。位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并参与关于节目的讨论。你可以在Twitter上@我（Roman Mars），在节目@99PI org。运营Instagram并让我们去。你可以在99PI.org上找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接，
as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. Your listening to a Stitcher, I'll get some serious exam! There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及99PI的每一期往期节目。你正在收听Stitcher，或者Sirius XM！本期节目尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。